why is it every time I go back and
re-watch Dragon Ball Z on my current
sets I am constantly accosted by some
ridiculous added lines that weren't in
the top originally like take this scene
for instance Majin Vegeta is powering up
his sick as hell attack and in the
original it's all ambient and Musical
and whatnot but then in the current
releases we have Bobby yelling over the
entire scene
do you hear me ribbons even as seen as
important as this one in the original
Goku says a few words then it's onto a
montage of booze Shenanigans but then in
the current version for FUNimation Goku
just monologues over the whole damn
thing it's like he became a drama kid in
between takes when I first met you I
could sense that there was good in you
you were like a naughty little child
that didn't know any better like I don't
know maybe I'm being old-fashioned but
these additions just seem so unnecessary
and get in the way of the atmosphere of
the original